top everybody knock worn out man yeah
torn up at Cobbs tore it up yeah you're
saying when you came in though your
throat it's a little sore there's gonna
be some soda in my voice bro is there
yeah I'm not it's not not suffering from
the rhinovirus
no suffering from no not hey and you
know why I'm in cobs right sounds like
you're suffering from you know what deep
throat dicta I'll see I don't appreciate
it Cobbs deep throat dick diving it's
what I got from Brennan I don't know
what this is is this gonna get me in
trouble no I'm busy anything shocking by
talking about drag to throw those take
them singing I'm like yeah using this
whole thing want my 40 seconds back
right now oh my god my thoughts all were
asked me to was it in cobs so there's no
evidence of me suckin pipe no but my
neighbors and a few people been telling
me it's from the ashes cuz I've run
outside outside yeah I think it's bright
from that I've heard that well you just
have a cold one of the other eye oh
they're right I think so I never know I
know that this is just like I woke up
and I was like is there a grapefruit in
my throat I can't swallow and then now
it's fine but it was it was I strained
it your about your throat muscles like
you learned this in theater school your
vocal cords muscles and they rub
together and if you um you know I've
never been a guy who loses his voice
I've always had I actually silently
judge men who lose their voice as not
manly like he'll depends if you're
thirty Seconds to Mars you doing back
back back
they talk to you and then I've had that
with people and then they're like I
can't talk right now
I'm like I stay home or I'm gonna
actually punch you in the throat because
I find it very unmanly and you you can
[ __ ] speak you can still do that
don't you if you're singing the wrong
way of talking or yelling the wrong way
then you get like I guess calluses you
do kick ass almost like Bob knows well
so we get nose yeah this is so funny
about the supplements people can make
funny for watching this but I was uh
couldn't sleep late late night I'm
clicking through I see this this I guess
documentary on the Backstreet Boys
mm-hmm I was kind of a fan was younger
sure chin was balls deep and I'm
powerful I was not but keep MJ you're
way too young for them you're familiar
with them I laid before you I have a
story about that yeah so so you know
they broke a couple number of years ago
but they were kind of the first boy band
right yeah well they all decide to get
back together cuz ain't no one doing
[ __ ] these days and they were gonna
shoot it so Nick Carter who's member of
the band decides everyone's going to go
to England London and write their album
in three weeks and then what they're
gonna do meantime is go to each band
members home to get their backstory to
bring them upon them closer together huh
and I was thinking can you imagine if
you're part of an and you're going
through your friends like imagine if you
came back home with me I'm taking you
through my high school I met you but I
don't give a [ __ ] now you know but
they're showing the dynamics between him
they have all these young videos you
know Nick was 14 or 13 and older son was
28 Wow and he was a Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle at Universal Studios oh [ __ ]
so you have twenty fourteen so they're
just different then obviously they go on
the road they blow up and you're up and
come back here but at 14 Nick's all over
he's basically with grown man you know
I'm sure they're doing some weird [ __ ]
yeah but then anyways fast-forward now
where no one's really doing [ __ ] they
all look way older drawn out and they're
trying to decide the songs on the album
and the one the one guy who was kind of
the lead singer the smaller one blond
hair I forget his [ __ ] losing his
hair but yeah you know Brian's losing a
chin Brian is hurt but all them King
kind of still sing hold
Brian's vocal pipes have given out so
they're going through rehearsal keeps
giving out and it's kind of like you see
it and he mentions it like he starts
crying he's like it's just it's there
and sometimes not and he's like singing
at church and then they're they're going
through rehearsal and you can see it's
there and you can see the banners like
look you toy alright and then there yes
the guy in the middle with that faux
leather jacket okay and then they're all
together going through the songs like is
he the young one who is the young this
is the youngest okay and then this is
the one with the vocal issues this is
the teenager studio 76 yeah he's 90 now
so he's doing well for that little one
Brian well they're all doing they made
shitload of money off Backstreet Boys
but the this story try and wrap it up so
we don't talk about Backstreet Boys this
time so but I got in the middle his
pipes are giving out but they don't
acknowledge it and then they're at a
meeting with their managers everything
and there's a camera and they get into
it and it was some epic TV Nick's going
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you why don't we just
bring it up why don't we just bring up
the elf in the room you can't sing
anymore how about you can't [ __ ] sing
anymore all right you see the best thing
air you can't sing anymore
Wow and it's an issue and he was in on
the record you're good enough at editing
where we can get through it and figure
it out but you know what when producers
come and go hey he can't sing anymore
and we don't tell you behind your back
don't hurt your feelings well guess what
you can't [ __ ] sing anymore
and they're about to come to blows I'm
like I'm slay ass in my undies oh crap
Batman and they can all sing right all
of them sing sing sing Psalm can sing
see he's three they yeah they can sing
yeah like that they just got created
because they all know it's gonna sound
crazy but was that Justin Timberlake's
man no no that was he's in sync and sync
which the guy who founded them who's in
prison now for all sorts stealing money
from the guy that started them they were
doing well blown up and then they came
home like who the [ __ ] are these guys
he's like almost start another band to
their direct competition which is Justin
Timberlake really yes now I'm gonna
think I'm self
damned in sync cuz I that's him look
yeah yeah yeah that guy's terrible he
did some salt Amy yeah
did I think actually yes Lou Pearlman
yeah I think Lou problem was a really
creepy dude so he's so sorry Backstreet
Boys call them he took care of himself
look at him
yeah he'd get all these young guys and
what didn't he go to jail for like
sexual I think he was still in jail he's
still in jail cuz he had some Ponzi
scheme you got bus yeah
millions and millions of dollars yeah
but then that so that Nick Carter's time
out he was the first time we ever saw he
was like our dad for some way I'm so
poor no was that his boy yeah he's like
I bought up on the big screen I'm like
oh he's for sure or fondled you're not
yeah for sure
yeah he's in prison now I mean I don't
mean to be mean but he he's he makes
Harvey Weinstein look like [ __ ] yeah
Brad Pitt put a little effort into your
yourself I mean Jesus
my buddy one time but boy could he pick
some boy be my buddy and I'm not right
and see yes sold so many records at
records some people are good if I'm less
on the way I'm not trying to shine light
on that but it's [ __ ] up that's I'm
sure he did I'm sure that's what he was
doing who else did he find didn't he
find someone else what O'Town was the
other group oh you never do yeah I had a
friend you know you have those moments
where your friend shows you a side of
heaven you go well this is just a game
changer for me like me tell my
Backstreet Boys no no but it'd be like
this so my buddy normal guy cool
producer hustler but in a good way and
one day cause I got to talk to how to
talk to have this really awesome idea I
go what and he brings me into the car
and we're driving and he's playing the
Backstreet Boys and NSYNC and he knows
all the words by heart like you sing
like yeah like well tell me why I'm
pitch you know I know
I'm pitch and he's going head there and
one I know she was like tell me why and
he was breathing it like the right way
and I was like hey man was that way to
tell me why man you ready
I am seasoning to the song bro you've
been singing this a lot that you're
actually taking liberties with the saw
you're breaking you're breaking out the
the boundaries here and he's damn and I
go what are you doing man
you know me I'm like what are you doing
old is he first of all ah 30 more 33 I
don't know what he is hey buddies out
there this is back in the day you know
he tells me what he goes I'm thinking
about starting a boy band and being in a
boy band I want to be the leader of boy
band oh you're dead serious I went out I
can't be friends with you anymore by now
I'll have to throw you in a flying
headlock for good yeah sure it's this
thing with these guys you see them now
and they they kind of want to break out
of this thing oh boy oh boy rather a man
bad they're still killing it are they oh
yeah oh they all were so successful
they're redoing it oh my god well you
know that's what people although make
seventy million dollars a year stone yes
all those fans you know they're older -
they still jam to him well remember the
Eagles right the Eagles in 1998 or
whatever I I was doing this thing and
one of the band members were there and
the driver their driver a long time - I
start talking to him and I said so so
must be tough for that man you know and
he goes you said well he goes why he is
she is what people don't realize because
they hadn't cut an album in what 12
years old man he goes they just made 50
million dollars on their their worldwide
tour like bit they fill stadium still
Bon Jovi oh well do me you time of the
big spans the world soon they're doing
well but I know guys like you know
you'll see a weird thing where it's like
boys the man
Jodeci like all y'all they all get
together and they still make tons of
money they all like right and you loop
together like even when I was in
Australia man that promoter shoutout to
what was his name oh it's we call the
shrimp shrimp shout-out to shrimp he was
talking about how he worked with vanilla
ice and I was like what a joke am i
right he's like yeah I know I get it
he's a he's a joke but he sells tickets
like he has a lot of money I'm like
still Ice Ice Baby I know an 80s band
maybe they were a little bit in the 90s
and they still tour and they make a
million dollars each from toy yeah and
that's a three-month tour not bad you
were I was talking about though like
with mean we both have kids like if your
son was like your Nick Carter he's 14
talented is tries out for this boy band
makes it and the managers like this Luke
I well if he's not touching kids with
legit guys sits down he goes I'd be your
son he'd fin he has all the skills man
we're taking on tour he's me gone around
the world for 300 days he's gonna miss
out on childhood he's gonna have some
fun but Jim he's there's no school but
he's the only friends probably be in the
band
he's never gonna have known this I hate
this right no right I hate it because I
was like in a John like I would I would
do not wish on Tiger Jake we don't like
no he they don't grow up normal they
don't get experience the normal things
and name like most of them don't turn
out I also think about what vans doing
what people don't realize is bands are
in a bus with each other I mean they
talk about that how they hated each
other how can you not
they're literally with each other what
band it was God who was it major band u2
hero Smith Daryl Smith at one time i
metallica metallica does he therapist
they know they wouldn't they wouldn't
talk to each other till they got on
stage but in office is just that makes
sense outside that yeah they just did
their own thing got together that makes
sense that's the best way to do it
because no human being especially a
bunch of men want to be around each
other 24/7 you go [ __ ] crazy you also
want your own thing though yes like you
they're like dude i don't want to be
[ __ ] metallica like I can [ __ ]
[ __ ] jam man I'd rather do this
project over here like if I'm gonna do a
project I don't want to have to get the
okay from four other grown men we have
our money yeah we're good well they look
amazing the bands that stick together
they're the other thing is um chemistry
you know sometimes it's just chemistry
and you have to stick with your
chemistry in it but it's tough it's
tough because that's the trick with most
bands is how do you keep the chemistry
when you don't want to be around each
other just because you're a human being
and you're in each other's faces the
lead singer of Smashing Pumpkins what's
the name of billion carbon really a
brilliant man but he was on Rogen he was
talking about how they hate each other
and then he made this deal because he
wrote all the songs then he got it
you know before they were all getting a
share of the pie equally and then
someone came on when I called up you're
the rider of all the song he goes yeah I
write all the songs they go well you're
gonna get this money now not only you
get this but you're getting this cuz
yeah you write the song and he goes
it seemed fair but I knew would create
some drama but I still did I she made
hundreds of millions of dollars doing
that but the recipe I was like [ __ ] you
man
and then he said they didn't talk they
go on stage and then the brand broke up
see there's always that I had such a
problem with that because it's like when
somebody's doing the work and the
writing you know you should check
yourself you should [ __ ] check
yourself like B people are just not
honest it goes back to that stuff like
people are not honest about what they're
doing like we're all doing this bro like
to serve anything know what you're all
doing it I get that but would you be
where you're at if Billy wasn't using
his creative brain to write those little
where would you be yet no Amelia Amelia
bloom who is the number one Tough Mudder
in the world she's some complete badass
like have you seen her she beats all the
men yeah I mean she's a killer
and they said what would you what would
you put on a billboard or something if
you could and she said I would have I
think Note Amelia I think she said I
would put nobody owes you anything and I
think that's a really good way to go
through life because people get this
idea that there something there she
dresses like a like an 80s spinster over
New York she knits 18 18 Wow she's
killing still well Tim Ferriss I don't
know if he still dates over used to he
told me like she baby like literally 25
miles away and she'd go can you let me
out here and he'd go what he goes well
just let me I'm gonna run back and he
goes we're 25 miles away if that [ __ ]
for then she goes I know it's fine yeah
yeah and she'd run back and then she'd
work out like she's just a different
kind of hearing me yeah that's an
individual sport though and not a band
so she don't have to worry about
chemistry and all that you know no what
was that what was the point of that I
don't know [ __ ] clue Brian where
because she goes motor no one owes you
anything in other words year
by yourself before no in other words in
other words nobody knows you're anything
as in because you know you know you're
not Oh Billy Corbin's share the [ __ ]
pie he wrote all the songs so just check
yourself like know your worth know what
you're worth some people think they're
owed stuff just out of nowhere just yeah
I mean when it's a band that came out it
depends it depends what who was in on
that I'm not creative process did maybe
the drummer inspire him to do something
and help out with that song and that has
an extension exploration in other words
if somebody writes the songs that's a
lot of work like to sit and write income
is you know yes at the same time the
question becomes with anything like any
business or anything this is a look you
and I've had this talk you do all the
work with the merch and you do all the
designing you know for me I was like I
don't feel like I should take like I'm
not doing anything and I'm just now I
still contribute we have this great
symbiosis that that the fighter and kid
is you know both of us but for me I like
I was like I don't know man I like I'm
doing no work that was your idea 50% the
money I don't like that because it's
really not fair to you you're doing all
the work all the packaging were all the
organizing all the designing and all
that that's a lot of work so why would I
get why am I entitled to 50% of that
because we built this together okay yeah
that's yes of course they that's great
no lady you say that but then it's on me
to be fair and go hey bro let's have a
talk because you're doing all this work
you should be rewarded for it otherwise
it becomes weird otherwise you've gotta
just the point is you got to just know
what proportion is but also money
shouldn't be the know the denominator
that kind of effort should be rewarded
you know and time should be rewarded and
after a while if you're doing all the
work and I'm getting 50% and I know I
know you probably wouldn't give a [ __ ]
at the end of the day it's just kind of
shitty it's kind of like I don't know
yeah uh how bands stay together I have
no idea I mean like I can't lie to them
imagine the Arrowsmith they still doing
the goddamn thing like you find ways to
cope they're also also they're all
they're all in the same like ecosystem
where they all kind of need each other
when you're in a band if home plate this
up
what though yeah yeah like blink-182 you
know they moved on but you know that the
issues with their singer and you know I
mean let's happen was never the same
when John Bonham died and you think a
drummer wouldn't make a difference his
drumming style his sound was so unique
and that was it
greatest in many ways greatest heavy but
how about the how about the Nirvana so
when Kurt passed away who's the who's
the drummer Foo Fighters David crawl
dance bro David goryl was talking about
how their relationship his relationship
with Kurt he goes you know I wish I
could say meet him were super close when
he passed away but we didn't talk for
like six or seven weeks is you know we
had our issues were arguing all the time
and he goes it was strange too because
he was on how [ __ ] Howard certain how it
goes have you cuz you know Foo Fighters
enormous success and they go he writes
all the songs most of them then we go
did you were you always a writer and he
goes yeah but there's nothing he was I
knew to your point goes I know my role
in the band of Nirvana cos Kurt was the
mastermind I don't want to be that
drummer Mike bro-bro you should sing
this he goes so I just kept quiet did my
job and then you know I would maybe give
him some notes here and there but you
had all these songs but that just at the
time I was at my Lane yet and I let him
do and their sound would aside and I you
know he could kick you Foo Fighters yeah
I guess he's one of my favorite people
on that really loved them he seems like
he's got a great sense here my so
talented me up yeah Joe pointed this out
cuz we're watching I forget but I'll
watch sports like I watched well I was I
was watching Loma chanko obviously and
then I was watching
they came with Wentz who got hurt but
and then we were watching some singing
thing
oh we're watching the Backstreet Boys
thing and I apparently I do this had no
idea she called me on it
I have got he's so talented and then
we'll watch them well say daddy so I
watch something else oh my god damn what
a talent and she just you know whenever
we watch so and he's really good at
something say so talent I'm like that's
cuz I appreciate it I like to
acknowledge that everyone
let's imagine the work that went into it
but every time like so tell me do you
know cuz I gotta stop that I was on
stage you know Saturday I missed the
lemon chenko I missed it on Saturday -
well I wanna record it and then watch
what did you think in the fight wasn't a
fight it wasn't a fight no wasn't a
fight brigand I landed I think averaged
three shots around God just it was just
like here his hand he's head this is my
thing this is my thing with maybe did
hurt his hand but you got to realize
lomachenko didn't get the knockout you
know he didn't get the vicious ko that
would be on highlights we got to realize
something there riggan Dow was a
two-time olympian two-time gold medalist
Green Opera has over four or five
hundred fights total on defeat as a as a
professional fighter boxer he was
literally out class and broke by
lomachenko do too
so to do that is more impressive than
going in knocked him out because maybe
bringing out came in with everything you
had and just gets caught you know I
can't we really don't know yet caught
you know like you know Jose Aldo type of
kind of thing for you to see la manche a
go break him six wrap didn't answer the
stool so for a guy of his magnitude to
go I can't I can't
I'm out like God and be like oh he
sucked whoa whoa whoa hold on ring endow
was the best in the world from his
country in two Olympic Games also this
the first time boxing history at the
professional level two guys who placed
in two different Olympics fought each
other and one guy made the other one
quit that's how impressive is there any
validity though his hand was broke he
couldn't throw
maybe there's another fight or no oh
they'll never fight again because it was
all that because you were able to serie
far too much for him he came up two
weight classes loma chancres a nightmare
form I'm not reading that was a bigger
guy no don't shake his big bringing that
came up to it costs to fight Romanenko
okay because they're by amateur
background their history and Olympics
everyone wanted to see it the style wise
you'll never see that fight again and so
interesting because his uh his father's
you know trained him
since he was little trains right his
father when he was 11 goes oh you're
southpaw real him changed like I'm
right-handed he's a mm-hmm southpaw and
he just wanted to get used to doing
south ball and so he he knows he'd pick
up the traditional Orthodox pleat he
just made him so you can do anything for
Kangol yeah everything from every angle
yeah that's incredible man crazy right
that fight was amazing amazing
so when you watch someone like Roman
chenko obviously this town involved
obviously well but his father had to be
like really kind of a very smart guy and
also you know I was a boxer to know what
his father did his father made him plate
every sport really his father made him
till he's 12 or 13 do soccer everything
non-stop uh-huh non-stop tennis he made
me do everything and then when he was 12
or 13 the seal told him length goes no
no I'm come on man I would be world
champion boxing right now you focused on
boxing but parents forget this man they
want their kid to go using me next
LeBron he's playing basketball
year-round that's not how you do it now
timeout Jose touts most Scouts most
professor sport Scouts want them to be
multi-talented want them to compete in
other sports if you remember football
players the coaches especially in
college and impro you still love when a
guy had a wrestling background release
has so much heart nice show game he's
tough
yeah they know he's gonna be tough yeah
that's funny because I was like quick
recently who works with the Eagles and
my quick was a he did he's not a Hall of
Fame wide receiver play of nine years
man I felt with the Eagles and was a
great great player play with Randall
Cunningham did was part of that
Eagles Super Bowl shuffle that that song
is doing yeah
Reggie White and he said that that Bach
wrestling is the one thing that he loves
to see on a resume but I'm high school
like yeah yeah yeah it's it because
because they find with junior tennis
players the kids that do really well in
the juniors been playing since there are
six like hours a day they burn out by
the time I get to the pros
it's not like someone lab solutely love
it like I loved football like I would
have played it year-round but it's just
if you did
I wanted to really what what did you
love about it football I just love pho
cuz you were bigger and stronger no I
was I wasn't big yeah I wasn't big and
strong yeah yeah when you buddy no small
but you and when you're a similar kind
of skinny I'm small would you wait 18
180 maybe damn yeah damn no but the the
point was is I like I wanted to but
they're just it's such a back then you
did everything basketball baseball it
wasn't now the parents think the you
know get your kids that level and it's
actually the wrong thing doing
matter-of-fact professional Scouts don't
want you doing that they don't know tell
you what Saturday morning though if you
ever seen those ESPN the the 60s I
forget what they call it 60 something
the slight it's not 30 for 30 it's there
it's their different show some e6000
but they usually have a story I this
last one I guarantee anyone in this room
and anyone list this watch and try not
to cry I'm talking really my eyes filled
up really yeah there was a coach Schwab
always cries no no no man this little
boy who like you if you look at him I
looked I used to look like when I was
little but he's like eight or nine he
might be ten eight or nine and he was
his you born in Philadelphia his goal
was always to be a Philadelphia ego he's
playing Pop Warner football his hero was
Wentz who just got hurt but the starting
quarterback for the Eagles he's probably
gonna be MVP but he should be but now
he's hurt to be an issue
anyways so he wanted me oh the little
kid starts feeling ill and then they
find cancer terminal cancer so then they
finally let him meet Carson Wentz when
he's going through chemo everything and
his spirits are still so high he meets
Carson Wentz they hit it off they go
back forth have a good time Carson Wentz
leaves town to do his thing kid dies hmm
when you see it in the moms talking the
moms like he's going through all this
pain he's going through all this pain
and he's like about to go out and he's
guy's mom and his mom away crying I'm
gonna be fine god damn you know and then
and then they go to Carson Wentz like
now I'm Carson and then the mom goes we
haven't been able to watch Eagles game
since he passed away because that was
our family thing with him like we'd
always watched the Eagles and then we
decided like no we should watch it you
know in his bed
they turn on the game and they see
Carson Wentz comes out and he's wearing
the the bracelet that the dying kid gave
him he's been wearing every game since
[ __ ]
crazy - I'm talking fireworks
I know yeah you know what I realized
this weekend I was so exhausted because
I was flying back and forth right
because I would wake up at 5:00 I led a
shot well I woke up a five-hour shot I
didn't take a plane to San Francisco I
do my show I wake up at 5:00 again I fly
back to LA I shoot all day and then I
get back on a plane I just made it I get
to LA I mean get to San Francisco and I
have two shows two I'm on stage for two
and half hours I was so tired and I
realized that I was so tired that I was
emotional like I was I I felt like
crying like I was like what the [ __ ]
like I'd see that commercial I was like
why do I feel like crying and then I'm
talking like three people who I don't
even know who are like dudes and I iced
there's a statue of Gandhi in at the war
at the pier at the wharf in San
Francisco and I said I go you guys know
do you know that what he famously said
to a guy who killed a small child during
the India's independence right and I
started to describe the movie there's a
Sita said hi I go and he said I know a
way out and all of a sudden I go you
were talking no I was just I go I go and
I go I'm about to cry I'm about to cry
because I'm overly exhausted I'm getting
emotional about a movie that came out
thirty years ago and I go I guess I look
off and I go I go then I go I said I go
no I had to pretend that I had a friend
I go I have heartburn or something all I
was like mmm it was so embarrassing
bring up I know a way that way out of
hell it's two seconds but it's oh you
know you know they say flying on
airplane copy I know the studies show
that flying on the plane makes you more
irrational is that true yeah because why
cuz that's what happens to hot you know
subconsciously you know that you could
die like your your your anxiety goes
even though you fighting they be they've
done a study where your
way more emotional on plane so if you're
flying a lot in like a few days you'll
be more emotional now I'm sure that that
is so [ __ ] interesting that this
whole study exactly but a more emotional
like when you're watching move yes
you're talking to someone but then they
also if you're doing it back-to-back
like flying all over it [ __ ] that's
interesting that's so I kept wondering
what the [ __ ] was going on with me I
would like I'd like to see a cat and
start to cry want to cry so let me just
give you the back on the scene so this
is a famous scene so that Gandhi's a
great move everybody should watch Gandhi
led India to its independence against
British rule and he did it with
non-violence he insisted that and when
India broke in 2010 and it broke into
Muslim and Hindu like a fight between
the two and that was why Pakistan was
formed in 47 by Muslims they actually
walked over to there so to the different
side of India and created them jinn so
he this is fed this is supposedly a true
story where he was on a hunger strike
and he was he was not gonna [ __ ] eat
until everybody in India put down their
weapons and this is a guy comes to him
watch this eat eat I'm going to hell but
not with your death on my soul only God
I killed a child I smashed his head
against a wall
they killed my son my boy
the Muslims killed my son
I know a way out and a child a child
whose mother and father have been killed
a little boy about this I would raise
him as your only be sure that he is a
Muslim and that you raised him as one
that's it stop it there dude and rate
suited for a Hindu to have to raise him
as a Muslim and they said that yeah to
do stuff man a powerful speech are you
piss his eyes on poori a famous actor oh
yeah yeah I think might have
yeah he's put a lot of stuff let's I can
you bring up more Connie videos [ __ ]
so we lose all fans no I'm just kidding
[ __ ] I love Gandhi man you better love
you better love got me who doesn't love
Johnny more does North Korea Wow Dennis
Rodman says he has secret message for
from Kim Jong hoon for Donald Trump all
right Dennis you're awesome dude I was
reading an article I don't want to go
crazy political on the show but with
Donald Trump and they his inside source
and what his day looks like yeah I'm mad
about that I sent it to you he got much
about 48 hours it goes wrong I do not
nor do I drink 12 diet cokes he's like
freaking 12 diet cokes
but they did some pretty extensive yeah
it's like from people within their like
it but they weren't eating on him like
that's what he does I got very worried
when I heard he watched his eight hours
of TV a day
he says that's not true yeah I don't
know I heard he's obsessed with
McDonald's - oh my god Ivysaur we know
that from we went to the White House and
we did like your private toward the last
night they told us his diet I mean that
there's nothing wrong if he likes to do
that do your [ __ ] thing the president
do whatever he wants also when you look
at his body it's not like that guy's
only in sweet potatoes and grass-fed
beef I mean you know he's obviously some
stuff yeah pretty successfully he [ __ ]
[ __ ] he has a theory in his mind of
Mirth that he says that if you exercise
too much said you have a battery right
in his mind he's like we're talking
about like dudes remember yeah he's got
he's got BS her number yes yeah he's got
you know good Germanic stock in there
yeah he's interesting yeah nothing about
him is surprising I
how about the I think are the fires
under wrap or they're worse top the
Thomas fire the Thomas fire most of the
bars are 75 percent contained
so I didn't bring that up Thomas fire
honey / - Thomas fire is the only 20 per
second so the Thomas yeah but the tie
was five incher and all that that that's
still a problem
Wow California water lava is larger than
New York City and Boston Wow
Thomas fires a [ __ ] do we know cuz I
thought it got worse because the Santa
Ana winds they said the winds everything
yeah but all the other fires have been
contained by 75% according to NPR this
morning I don't know if it's changed but
that's what I saw
that's what I heard 15% contained for
the Thomas for ya San Diego yeah there's
one contained 93% continued
yeah but the Thomas fire is still a
[ __ ] man da-ding
yeah it's no joke no joke
and people were allowed back in and then
they found their dogs and the course is
all burned to death sucks man it's
really bad such a bummer you don't know
where to go yet to grab if there's if
the fire was about to hit your house you
have to grab three things what would you
grab not my dog talking about my dogs
have been [ __ ] in the pukin everywhere
and just let him go I love my dogs but
gotta get another dog yeah
alright I get my kids well that doesn't
count alright tail obviously you um so
what three things the guns the passport
home against do you have to okay there's
two you have one more thing to get come
on no only three but those two gods
count as one thing nope only through
mine so what you gonna take my take my
guns um you don't want to fire like you
know there's bullets go off um what else
my passport they say most document well
the password for sure see most us my
hands make sure
electronically yeah and so you're not
carrying all this [ __ ] my phone of
course are your cell phone so you bring
your gun cell phone laptop three things
well dude I have my cell phone on me my
wallet my cell phone my car is it weird
is there anything like material that
you'd like I gotta grab this I know
no I always go through this [ __ ] in my
head like what would I bring
well now you should be well you should
with this fire stuff because I was
seeing a thing where people had to
literally grab three day only had time
you got three things so is the question
you're in the wilderness you need water
and you need fire you need warmth you
need water
where's water where's the water at you
know and it's hard when you go down like
your planes in the Sierras or something
you're not gonna find water well I'm
just talking about these forest fires in
LA so you're not gonna die bro yeah
gonna have water well listen listen up
you just drive down to Brett wedding I
mean is it yeah I know you need clean
water brother though do you have water
cleaning devices yeah I do I don't know
if you do it'd be tough class yeah
another question in your trunk do you
have gloves that does make you strong
I've Club okay cuz you need gloves to
handle [ __ ] in the event of an emergency
your hands get cut up real easy know
this yeah there's nothing I would
materialistic that would grant I mean I
wear my watch yeah oh that's all I can
be replaced whatever give a [ __ ]
yeah I don't know what what would you
take from my house nothing okay oh my
clothes damn it
all those sweaters and I got a couple of
cashmere sweaters how dare you know what
are we talking nothing crazy yeah yes
some convention yep wait what'd you guys
do this weekend
Jen I just looked at camera stuff all
weekend long
well for when we move it on alive for
the live feed or you just talk to you
concerning uh I always look for those
cameras as well all the live stuff but I
was just looking at like vlogging kind
of cameras just cuz you know we've been
doing the behind scenes stuff yeah
people love them but the GoPro audio
sucks I told you it's it's terrible loss
behind the scenes you don't really the
audio is not really I know but still
and then plus the nicer camera just for
me also what do people say to use
Canon's SL DSLRs and then I'm also
looking at Panasonic the Newton case but
then you carry like this well I guess
the go there just a little bit bigger
yeah but the GoPros are good because you
could just boom grab it and go that's
why we like it yeah that's why I like it
but if you're getting around a big s
camera like the [ __ ] 9news that's
gonna be an issue not huge it's about
like this size but then of course it's
like $2,000
they're crazy expensive yeah what else
did you what did MJ do cool you're done
but yeah so you on winter break till
when Jesus Christ we're gonna do with
all your time yeah I could never do yoga
twice a day I mean so you want to live
so you say so your your goal is just to
do your full time you wouldn't want a
life where you doing yoga every day like
you might be like
Bikram yoga guy we're just a billion off
yoga yeah eventually that'd be pretty
cool if I could do something maybe that
involves kids who's like special needs
but that's full not MJ it's my point
here course I do but to well to make to
do yoga to make money you'd have to
start like you I need for ending it well
like I'm trying to patent the name
Meraki movement and that way I can start
like running a brand like Rocky movement
rocky movement Kuzma Rocky means like to
leave a piece of yourself within
whatever you do and so within every yoga
practice I always set my intention and I
leave everything from before I send my
attention on the mat everything's just
there I can refresh what one good thing
to do that they've it sounds
counterintuitive but you just have a
donations only thing Bryan Kest did that
for years and made a fortune and he was
just like I teach yoga if you want to
try Mike
no problem donations there for the most
part straight people go I'm haven't he's
an amazing teacher and they were like
I'm giving their that plenty people with
enough money they're like here's 50
bucks is depend with our yoga training
established too right
not before he was established way before
that's how we tell for mjid do donations
only I need photos I've been so caught
up with school and whatnot so I'm gonna
take it easy next semester because it's
hindering a lot of like my opportunities
I've had like right now and you want to
be a yoga instructor though I'm always
gonna be yoga instructor for the rest of
my life that's cool forever I guess it's
something I'm constantly every year I
try to do at least one more training
I have 400 hours of like yoga which was
the national registry right now benches
wantoniy own studio
I'm I will eventually I will have one I
don't know if it's coming my main
priority but I will have one because
it's a simplicity it's simple all you
need is a hardwood floor installations
to make it hot keep it clean so you need
very little materials easy labor
thank you but would you need to keep
going through school if all you want to
do is yoga though I don't know I didn't
all my business classes the past few
semesters I'm just I like them but I
think I should to go towards just
focusing more on kinesiology so I was
trying to do both and I just been doing
business the past two semesters and I
feel like yoga is something more drawn
to expecially with my injuries I come
from experience of broken back broken
ankle hopping in a walker going through
you know crutches and how to like heal
yourself to go back into you know
surfing I'm on my I'm bartending I'm
doing all these other things and getting
people back on track so injury
prevention is my biggest thing so maybe
I need to go more into like anatomy and
body cuz I think that's what I'm drawn
to you and I enjoy it's good now nice
awesome you know
chinkyu gesture yoga class hmm yeah you
don't teach one in LA right but yoga is
not just about the physical practice
there's eight limbs to yoga so a sauna
which is the physical practice is one of
the eight limbs that you have to
constantly be turning into to be at
peace
sounds like you always kind of like an
octopus what do you mean eight limbs
hadrian's how about MJ's octopus yoga
octopus yoga study octopus seven
dope-ass octopus is your logo
cephalopods I'll have the two squid
masters come in oh my yeah yeah well
square the Kraken yeah so crass and we
just disrupt the class yeah
all right what do you got chin all right
first one you sent me actually a guy
that watched the movie the B movie three
hundred fifty seven times in the UK oh
how about Netflix is releasing some like
that I wanted X what do they say about
it they they do like a year a year-end
review of what I guess what people are
watching and they found that this one
dude was watching it three hundred fifty
seven times this one person what so at
least almost once a day that's him
that's impressive
I guess he just it was a source of
comfort for him I guess Jerry Seinfeld
being the voice of the bees what did it
for I don't know I guess so strange
some people will lock they'll anchor
into a movie if they they're hysterics
or they have anxiety and that's the one
place my friend was dying of pancreatic
cancer he knew he was gonna die and
every single day he would watch this
incredible like it was like a I don't
how to describe it but it was like this
documentary almost or like this art film
about elephants and water they'd be
swimming in water bring it up for a
second and you might be able to bring it
up it was like these elephants and this
Cameron had these elephants in water and
then this woman like you know kind of
like riding on their trunk and it's it's
like really hypnotic but it's the one
thing that kept his really things I lay
down but that was the one thing what was
it called soul of an elephant just give
me a now this can be literally
impossible an art thing so cool typed an
art thing and there was music like oh me
tough to find
anyways elephant riding water no it's an
art thing [ __ ] yeah it's me elephant in
water
no not documentary just put elephant in
water it's really gonna be off and
swimming in water well there's the move
on hold on a second
water like guys I'm telling this give me
little is it is it water relevance no it
was a great movie was but this is
literally impossible to find guys it's
so cool it's art there's elephants the
waters seem tough
now I want you to see it swimming in
water yeah there is there is I think no
that's just a three hour better be no
that's just him swim you don't know
check it out maybe we're not finding it
guys I'll do the music ah is that a
right there I think it is yes well this
this is just a three-minute video brain
well this was a long oh look oh this is
the making of it this is the making of
it anyways you would watch this over and
over again
yeah on a huge screen TV smoke weed it
sounds like this guy watching the B
movie once a day as a grown man it's a
little different a little strange maybe
it's yeah well we're it's the same
mechanism where I'd like to keep some
comments a routine healing with some
problem I'll tell you what I'm [ __ ]
glad Netflix uploaded the trolls holiday
season because my son will not shut the
f up about cars I'm so sick of cars in
moaña but he loves people watch it over
over and over he'll go we'll be sitting
there knob trying to watch the goddamn
game we go cars again alright so can
they just uploaded a new one I love
Netflix just uploaded a new one
there was no mater's [ __ ] whatever
the guy from cars it blowed that and
then they uploaded the new trolls
holiday cartoon thank God the thing
about Netflix is it's hard to know what
they release like you know they have
like new releases or you know just added
but there's there's like the marketing
there's not a ton of stuff that's like
stranger things or something like that
what's what's funny for them so let's
say your comic like our boy Tom Segura
has a special coming out I think he's
just third or fourth one on there you
don't know you know if you're doing
three or four specials like Rogen ham
you know it's going well but you have
idea what the numbers on him so
negotiating you have no idea it's the
same the same thing with like Howard
Stern and his numbers like you have not
they have no idea they know they get
this many listeners but they don't let
you know who's watching what what's
doing this but if they asked you do it
again you're doing pretty well yeah like
I'm Netflix like Tom obviously killing
it it's his third or fourth one on there
if you had if you had one we're gonna
have him on a probably didn't go well
yeah we're gonna have them on you know
in that strange sound looks like if
you're negotiating like well dude we
have no idea how the hell it's doing I'm
like yeah that's done well it's no no we
need to know for money-wise but wait
what is she gonna do like take your
leave at jump that's right
straight right huh what a powerful
negotiating tool for net for incredible
man smart very smart what else get Jen
all right we don't have to talk about
the story but just in case you guys want
to you know about that guy that Arizona
police officer that shot someone he shot
a guy named Daniel shaver hold uh hold
on could let me know if I'm wrong on
this chicken was this was dude who's in
a hotel in Arizona and he had sniper or
assault rifles you know shoot out his
hotel window that's what they thought in
the beginning yeah okay but he's
actually an exterminator he works for a
pest company and he's it's the air rifle
to kill pests oh oh and and then oh you
know what and then this they so they
they think there's guns in the hotel
room like they think he's can do Vegas
they get him out he's they're going no
please don't shoot me please
I did nothing and then he goes to like I
forget like he almost goes he goes like
this and the cop thinks he's gonna gun
the cop base he executes them yeah let
me say that's not plan yeah it's a super
long video basically okay people think
he was also drinking in the hotel room
and he was with his chick so he's
already kind of like buzzed as is but
then when the cop came over here that
you the cop if you actually listen to
the video he seems like a douchebag like
he wants that guy to make a mistake
correct well yeah and by the way if
you're in that position and you get shot
by a cop oh I think that's murder he the
cop asked him to crawl to him
so that's why he was crawling and then
and then he he goes you know I like when
you're crawling like you your shirt
comes up he goes he goes to go like this
to bring it down and when he goes like
this five times or something it was
horrible definitely execution-style yeah
hard to defend the guy have to say I
think I don't know I haven't seen it
we'll definitely watch it later but I
don't show it on how it's sad yeah so
the cop had a thing on his gun like
itched in it says you're [ __ ] like
written in there this guy's an [ __ ]
and he wanted to be an actor before he
was a failed actor yeah you gotta watch
the video later it's trippy not yeah
yeah he's he's cleared he's lawless on
the Spanish news this morning cleared
yeah he's clear yeah he was clear he was
cleared he's no conviction he was up he
was charged for murder or homicide like
that here right yeah so he would just
actually yeah hey you know what's
interesting and I'm not even trying to
race with her but imagine if this was a
black guy there would be riots
everywhere I don't like people say
anything that's this piece of [ __ ] no
this is the guy that died it's gonna
that died I'll just show you the picture
of the cop it's real a real bro I seen
this a real light bro it's such a bummer
man well there he is I mean not to judge
him on looks funny but that's him that's
the guy oh boy yeah it's a real shame
that's the cop you guys a piece of [ __ ]
and he's still I guess the problem is no
no the problem is he gives cops a bad
name no he was gonna go to prison for
[ __ ] executing a man but he got off
there's no one protests in this gin
there no white people know there's a
huge bad white lives matter so this is
one he was trying to be an actor I think
bad guy yep just a [ __ ] it's a shame oh
okay so I know everyone here saw this
already a kid she's meeting Joan
who's being bullied and and literally
all the huge celebrities although you
have C fighters everyone is is backing
him up and inviting them over to their
things like the FCC said red carpets
everything MBA
what happened him he looks he had an
operation on his head and stuff I think
it's some people are just born just
think he's different Brian that's what
he's getting bullied
okay did you see the video Brian right
Brian have you seen the video I watched
it it made me really sick looks like
there and moved yes yes i watch a little
bit of it yeah what they tell you at
lunch
where is it other kids to be criticized
think of European who have a parent your
heart their hearts break see when you
have children man like just hits the
home even harder man that's like poor
little dude man little to those chumps
know who are bullying them you know I'm
saying like those kids who are different
than ones I'm gonna be creating all the
cool [ __ ] that you're watching or
they're the ones that do different
things that you won't even think of but
you meanwhile well you're bullying and
thinking you're being cool and friend
your friends yeah you're turning these
dudes into these diamonds man yeah
but looked at the outreach for this kid
has just been everyone at all the sports
star how do you believe this day and age
you know I'm saying like if you're just
if you're a [ __ ] kid I get it to them
but man I never ever ever
bullied anybody I never got it and there
understood it is made me feel bad I just
don't get it man but there are people
who do that you know and I think a lot
of times they're just dumb they just
don't know what their impact is they're
just being mean it's like a group of
guys and it's just their way of you know
I don't know important Malcolm and [ __ ]
and bullying them every day there's
different levels of people who are who
lacked the sensitivity or the
understanding of what they're doing law
wave they're raised like god bullies
it's them lashing out because maybe that
home it sucks or some throne
insecurities well I'm just again people
did a lot of people I hate to tell you
man we can say it's this it look
sometimes people suck they just left I'm
those people that believe go on to just
be shitty people and you know that when
you see also there's that mob mentality
some people are very different when
they're when they're alone and when they
get in a group they can easily be they
can get whipped up to do anything
including gang rape okay is what happens
yeah he's a good guy I don't know but he
was he joined in on the gang rape with
that girl that they held down in a
factory or where the [ __ ] it is or for
that matter you know there was a rumor
this woman and there's a video of it
this woman in Afghanistan there was a
rumor she basically called out these
dudes for being there were swindling
customers they were selling things that
didn't work some gadget and then they
just spread a rumor about her right
there in the marketplace said she burned
the Koran and a group of group 1 group
whisperer Network all of a sudden they
started following her and next thing you
know they stoned her beat her and killed
her you know people get a new group what
is what you say what let's join let's
say hey and what it is it's actually as
sick as it sounds it's a bonding
experience this happens you bond you
bond together you know based on your
oppression of one other person but jokes
on them now those kids the funniest or
the most popular kid in the school
you [ __ ] LeBron James [ __ ] Joe [ __ ] I
like Joe showing much the next thing
LeBron James jr. Smith Dwight Howard
Dana why I'm you talking literally
entertainment he's gonna go to the the
vengers premiere he's gonna be just as
[ __ ] Batman like Superman Batman
Wonder Woman like
now now now he's gonna be the biggest
kid in the [ __ ] game yeah joke's on
you bullies you nerds I gotta take
social medias you know I mostly stay off
it but my god is it nasty i just got
online I follow just the political
websites like you know and it's just a
blip but that's what politically breath
people's arguing but I'm talking about
among like academic soup their adults
are in their 40s and 50s nasty [ __ ] I
can't imagine this stuff man and you're
right you talk about bullying behavior
online like kids who suffer from it holy
[ __ ] I can't imagine any worse oh my god
you're behind people try boy I mean
Kevin Hart if you I mean name a hot girl
that people try cyberbullying them they
get they get a rise out of I kind of
maybe make making them feel bad or
something like that again it's just it's
these losers in basements or these
losers that don't add value to the world
that are doing this stuff that's what
that's what it is yeah I really never
engage in it Jamie now have fun with
like I posted the the guy who won the
heisman the guy who won the [ __ ]
Heinz and get understand was a walk-on
at Texas Tech hey if you know anything
about walking onto Division one program
which I do it's impossible to make the
team let alone become the struming
because you're not recruited you walk on
that you walk on and try on it no one
has your back no one has your back
you're a guy for you the all odds are
against you it's hard enough to make it
in division one football then here's
your walk-on literally all had to be on
God so she have to be on stock against
you so he walks on Tech's Tech what
didn't you know he played there wasn't
great fit cuz he always wanted to play
big-time ball walked on in your see
Oklahoma won the Heisman first walked on
ever to win the Heisman quarterback
she's clearly a quarterback sir what a
difficult position well yeah but when's
the Heisman is a walk-on and I posted I
went a victory for every walk-on ever
and the people start hating on them
see what if I see it early on my going
so I see one guy hatin on him he's like
y'all [ __ ] this guy he's the loser this
and I went click and I never really
engage in it sometimes it's fun to roast
them yeah and I put oh I'm sorry love to
see your awards and accomplishments like
that how can you hate on the guy cuz the
guy mean if you're even if your lawyers
love to yeah it's crazy yeah maybe maybe
but still I hope you don't have a what a
waste of time what a waste of time to
sit on online and criticize people who
accomplish things you've [ __ ] zero
take a look at yourself I have this
strange man
oh we've seen videos like this before
right I could have sworn we saw all that
kids being you know lashing out on
bullies and stuff a little poses but for
some reason this particular one just
touched everyone around the world like
super super hardcore yeah this one could
you see how the kids hurt I'll see the
kids probably not the most beautiful kid
in the school
Yas he has some you know issues with
that you know and him just getting
bullied and him crying how you know he's
well spoke to he you know he brought up
the issue hmm
that's the mom now huh you know yeah I'm
sure you just want to go up there and
beat the [ __ ] out of those kids just but
that doesn't help
no honey now the little dude's I mean I
scheduled he's booked for the next three
years doing appearances its ballin it's
true the celebrity da
joke's on you bullies he's a slurry now
now did you have tickets for The
Avengers premiere for you maybe maybe
he's a good guy maybes gonna bring a
plus-one maybe it's one of you take dad
know what else you got [ __ ] oh my god
that's a fun one someone did a swap on
Donald Trump and Kim jong-un their
hairstyles that's fantastic hair swap
mmm he actually kind of looks like a
little bit like Donald Trump with Donald
Trump's hair kim jong by the way is
between 33 and 35 years old everybody he
weighs yep he weighs about 300 pounds
he's five foot maybe eight both Oaks
both their hairs awful yeah
neither ones that work that hair does
not work I just think Kim yong-joon no
one tells them how shitty is here cut is
like you get have you have any stylist a
wild dog sir yeah but if you're like his
boy for just like no well let's just say
yet a boy I'm sure you have the right
hand man who cares yeah god no I know
but you've just like probably heard
something crazy what there's this new
haircut I guess everyone's doing it
should we try it out I mean I about
yours you're just sick I'm not saying
you should change it yeah I'm just
saying saying we should try this you
know what maybe I'll do it if you like
it you do it yeah instead of that
[ __ ] simple Jack haircut you got from
North Korea I think that's his around
the world we're all laughing at you his
dad his dad's dad I think y'all have to
say my coat how about Donald Trump
you're the president United States you
got more money than God and just that's
the best you got
yeah it's always been that way I know
that's this thing if these hairs this
thing like you liked it cuz my games
were there he in his mind you have to
remember is he is always awesome and
he's always right and anyone who
disagrees one is the enemy and a bad
person but here cut you got a look at
your hair and then if you're saying next
to the dude with really good here like I
surprised you some like that he says
that he was when he played basketball he
was one of the best basketball players
in the state there's no real record of
it but he was a great basketball player
apparently he was great at everything
he's Donald what else you got he's the
Donald a boxer had his ear almost torn
off this is that HBO boxing after dark
and they stopped the fight at like round
nine because his ear was actually
getting torn off and you can kind of see
how bad it is right there that's not
good
what's his name Fergus snow Smith Smith
na'toth he's actually uh Steven Smith
yeah he actually trained with Tony
Jeffries oh yeah he was looking good in
the fight my god what the [ __ ]
ripped her ear like that in boxing a
punch a punch Jesus swifty Smith that's
right goddamn that that's almost worse
than the girl in the of Caesar sound
Alexis Davis yeah
it's about to fall off this is the worst
I've actually seen it's pretty bad
because it's not cauliflower let's just
straight Rip's here got rid he seems
like he has bigger ears so it's probably
he'll be fine
you sniff that up will be good yeah I
was like Robbie Lawler no one had that
crazy split all the way I like just just
limping uh-huh you had one yeah but the
lip makes sense you've been punched in
the lip ears you don't really see rip
off yeah that's kind of crazy lips I
mean everyone has bustle is busted eyes
cuts on your eyebrows your ears I've
seen to take a left here Cheers right
yeah it was like just like caught it
though what else get chin I don't know
much about this soil but I won't show
you this one I'll show you this one this
is just funny mountains new girlfriend
but what wild yeah but what girl's gonna
make him look small like I'm any girl
he's next to he's enormous
yeah you know yeah he's [ __ ] cute
enormous who is she
some girl named Kelsey Henson she's
super super hot she's five to five times
though they are in Iceland I just a man
yeah again I think of that squirrel
trying to swallow that banana it looks
like she's like shocking at this guy's
so big any girl unless it I don't mean
in the WNBA player I mean they're all
gonna be tiny
he's the mountain man for god sakes he's
like Jesus what is he six nine four
hundred pounds or something crazy yeah
it nice seven I see seven feet you just
play basketball your before now yeah he
was thin back then but he's relatively
you see he's not even 30 yet she's five
- I miss pretty standard yeah not like
heels on yeah but any girl next to his
giant ass you know it's small yeah he's
a real beefcake kidding me he's a beefy
he's beefy beefy he looks like he smells
like bratwurst and sauerkraut okay
probably takes on a lot of food oh my
god I told you
guys on Game of Thrones Mike it's
ridiculous man oh really
yeah ridiculous how much heat non-stop I
bet never full and he's a is he the
strongest man in the world or one of
them he wanted multiple times but
sometimes but he's let them that's
impressed a new champ
that's crazy impressed you know he has
Bell's palsy no no you selfish son
Bell's palsy Bell's palsy in on his face
yeah when he talks now does it flare up
periodically or I think it does yeah so
sometimes he looks kind of normal your
face will sag on one side it almost
looks like you had a stroke right yeah
yeah crazy strong six nine four pounds
see that's only gotta make gold well
okay right there the guy who passed away
all rich yeah this guy this guy passed
away yeah he was like a legend that gold
rich guy you've seen it might be yeah
just to beefcakes just big men just not
enough protein shakes in the world oh
yeah what that guy died of a heart
attack or something would happen then
yeah I think so yeah hmm big dude oh boy
that's a big change for Jorn son yeah
there is like John from 1 to 28
he's like a thin basketball player but
it's gotta mean Hobbs a huge frame yes
you have skeptical hip eyes on the peds
B wait let's see yeah are you suggesting
are you thinking
look at him they're 17 athletic
good-looking kid but I mean are you
saying that you could have done peds to
get that thick that's not fair yeah in
Iceland the strongman competition you're
not you're not competing at that high
high level without little help I mean
what do you mean Iceland in the world do
you know one is correct sir
that is correct sir beefy boys the
science to it doesn't take anything away
from their insane con accomplishment
though that's [ __ ] hard he's so big
yeah oh there he is Wow
he's nuts to be that strong he was great
in that and that show it's really yeah
well no they didn't kill mom a mountain
it's so huge peak dude what else you got
Jen I got one more but I don't know much
about it I just saw it
ba Hannibal Buress yeah you see this B
how is it gonna be bad he got arrested
in Miami right yeah and his mug shots
hilarious I think yeah well is this the
video funny dude there's a video yeah
he's great he's just wasted right I
think it's just yet little buzz and
having fun with the cops
it's just a bunch of that and I think
one of the jokes he made was can you
call me an uber he was telling the cops
can you call me nuber he looks like he's
probably drunk yeah yeah no [ __ ] no it
says intoxicated you know he's just a
waste I might add a ball all right that
was it and then he's out yeah it's not a
big deal I saw on the news it's really
not a big deal no his mug shots awesome
people need you better mug shots cuz you
know especially if you're somewhat
famous it's giving you it's gonna go
viral as a [ __ ] yeah they get
you get your [ __ ] right if you pull over
B don't be like at all dude I got a seal
it up I got a rugged face brother you
know just do that just keep my lips off
fool I don't think they can tell you not
to smile just flirt with them yeah do
that
hey officer where were you hiding you're
like a phantom I mean I've got pretty
good eyes some say beautiful eyes but
don't forget oh man whatever you do
don't shoot
is that a gun or your dick that might
work oh that wasn't armpit hair guys
blaming on the Wardrobe
oh jeez sometimes when you do wear black
shirts
yeah it's true you can cheat yeah ideas
I got [ __ ] giant force she's got like
we should worth its F fortune she's got
some product line
she's from me she's Palestinian I think
her dad's uber rich I thought she made
the money see what happens see what
happens
no he told me ah damn it well she does
have a good line I guess yeah but her
dad is one most powerful people in LA I
say she's all the points for everyone
she had a leg up or not she got she's
beautiful though
yes that it chin that's it man good
stuff got a dropping knowledge let me
just cope here alright yeah okay I just
want to really quickly here's my here's
my dropping knowledge just please like
the first rule the science is ignorance
is pleading your own ignorance knowing
that you are ignorant ignorant to the
truth until the evidence proves
otherwise so can I just give you guys an
example the reason that astrologers
what's the difference between as
astrologer and an astronomer astronomers
study the movement of the planets with
lots of math and lots of science and
they change their minds all the time
because they're wrong often and admit to
being wrong and they always start with
two words doubt and ignorance about what
they know and you should always keep
that and always be open to the idea that
if there's new evidence that everything
you built your platform on including
your life's work might be wrong that's
what science is when you're an
astronomer I mean when you're an
astrologer and you read stars you are
always right because there is a way of
reading the movement of the planets that
is concrete it's concrete it's and isn't
that the difference between philosophy
and religion I've talked about this
before but I want I'm getting to a
larger point with philosophy you know
reason and argument and even mathematics
and logic are what rule the day so that
means that you're kind of changing your
mind there might be more than one truth
but the idea that there's just one fixed
truth one true truth and everything else
is wrong that would be the difference
between that and religion
I'm not saying religion doesn't have its
place but be very careful about fixed
truths and I've been on social media and
I was listening to I mean it is just
people are forgetting that you're
supposed to try to persuade the other
side and most people on the right and
the left and I think mostly on the left
but I'm being a little bit unfair but it
feels like most of them are way more
interested in punishment than persuasion
and you're not gonna [ __ ] change the
world
punishment you just not try to persuade
and be open and responsive to the
evidence that you see and I think
there's an epidemic of people wanting
the truth and being on their side my
sides rooted in the truth and love your
saturated in falsehood and evil that's a
surefire and then you call each other
[ __ ] names
you're never gonna solve the problem in
the middle so that's what I think we are
suffering from in the public square
I think social media has a dark side to
it Twitter is a nasty [ __ ] place
even among adults who are highly
educated can be yeah
and I just don't I'm not on it the way
you guys are so it's a bummer I got
exhausted what reading it I got [ __ ]
exhausted I was like well what are we
trying to solve here man negativity man
yeah let's put our diet ideas together
your idea my idea not totally good ideas
but maybe we'll have a little idea sex
you know what I'm saying you know I'm
saying they're gone for idea sex I get
an idea what's that buddy how would you
tell us your dates man ask somebody in
Schaumburg the choke a slide Chicago
yeah Schaumburg outside Chicago then I'm
in Nashville
well you just came from Saintes a days
Nashville wait this weekend I'm
Schaumburg baby Chicago yeah outside
Chicago Sean Burroughs a through
Saturday Thursday through Saturday and
you tickets at E fat K calm or in the
Nashville Nashville is at Zanies as we
said and Nashville you know low no I
know where the [ __ ] it is why would you
why this is how you stop for time what
were we what are you asking me Nashville
Oh Nashville is easy Nashville I'm
obviously gonna be in I'll be there
January 11th 12th and 13th all perfect
kind of a dumb question has to be can
you're 11 12 and 13
go see Bryan in Schaumburg right outside
Chicago Thursday Saturday and then
zany's January Wednesday I'm off to
Syracuse Syracuse shows almost sold out
Syracuse I'm at the funny bone in
Syracuse New York Syracuse and then
Thursday through Saturday two shows a
day
two shows a night I'm at the helium in
Buffalo I know there's snow thank you
guys for update me on the weather we
will all be bundle up together let's do
it Buffalo see you this week and then
January 11th through the 13th I'm in
Portland Portland let's do this and then
the big one there are less than a
hundred tickets left
do we sell the Wilbur theater out Wilbur
theater Boston January 19th the day
before the big UFC 220 steep a verse
Francis in Ghana boom
June 19th 100 tickets left Boston get
him T fat K calm for Brian and myself
this is the fired kid we're out